Game 12 and possibly the world
championship title slipped through his
fingers after a strong opening by nepo
an error by Ding and Brilliant 25th move
NEPA was on the cusp of Victory before a
shockingly error-filled sequence by both
players turned everything around oh my
goodness the evaluation went all the way
up in dingley Run's favor Queen B7 was
ding's Choice he also doesn't find the
best move say these guys are just fried
at this point the decisive moment came
when nepo saw that Ding was low on time
and he rushed F5 hoping to put pressure
on ding's clock
it's losing the spot
had a world champion title which is
right there in his hands after just four
more moves Nepal resigned Han shakes and
that is it and thus somehow